welcome everyone to this topic on
docker tutorial for the beginners here
now in this one we are going to talk
about the various components
for example what is the devops here why
the devops is important
what is docker the advantages of docker
installation of docker architecture of
docker
components of docker game so these are
the different things which we are going
to talk about over here
now let's start with what exactly is in
devops all about here
now devops is nothing but a
collaboration between the development
and the operations teams over here which
enables continuous delivery of the
applications
and services to the end user so it's a
combination or collaboration between the
two teams development and operations
which helps us to go for a further
implementation of various processes like
continuous integration
continuous deployment continuous
delivery all these things are possible
with this collaboration
over here now why exactly docker is
important
for us as such in a city far away from
this one
so a developer decided to develop a tons
of software on a single vm
now he can put up applications he is
having a big server and he wants to
host the the multiple application on a
single machine but
for him these virtual machine got a
crash because
definitely if you are putting up more uh
different different applications as such
on the
on a single vm uh it's not able to take
up that much kind of
load over there so in order to avoid
this situation how exactly
he can do the various options or what he
can
implement to have this issue resolved
so ultimately docker is something which
is the solution of him
so if he really wants to host multiple
applications
on a single virtual machine or you want
to have different different applications
then docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that
and by doing so there will be no
issues as such when we talk about that
the
errors or the uh virtual machines cannot
be crashed and
but there will be no impact on the
virtual machine as such so why exactly
docker is important so let's talk about
the comparison between the docker and
virtual machine
there are very few reasons why exactly
uh the docker is
being chosen open a virtual machine
because virtual machine is a
full-fledged
component which can take up any kind of
load but some of the reasons
are still that in which case we will be
preferring the docker
instead of the virtual machine here the
very first one is the memory users
so docker is having a very less memory
users because
there is no concept of guest operating
system whereas on the other hand the
virtual machines are going to take a
huge amount of ram
uh resources in order to keep that
particular operating system up and
running
second one performance because uh if
definitely if you have less
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better
but for some reason if you are taking up
more resources and
you will not be able to deliver that
amount of performance
as such over there and then again we
have portability
so portability is also quite easy when
we talk about the
virtual machines in case of docker it's
quite
portable as compared to the virtual
machine and then the last time is that
the boot up time so virtual machine boot
time is probably in minutes but uh
in case of docker it's in seconds so if
we summarize it
on this one so the memory utilization
the
boot up time the performance everything
is better
in case of docker as compared to the
virtual machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory
uh you know is something if you can see
that one f2 and f3 is there
so green and red color represents the
occupied memory and the wasted memory
now there is a particular uh utilization
of let's say that um you know a server
which is available there
and uh you know uh 3gb of uh
ram is something which is wasted and 4gb
of ram is something which is being
occupied there so app2 is a using like
2gb
and then you can see that the specific
2gb of ram is
occupied and 3gb is occupied and the
wasted one is 1gb so
vm can see over there that uh you know
9gb of ram is used and
the remaining 6 gb of unused ram cannot
be reused
because if for example i allocate like 4
gb of ram to the virtual machine
it's there itself it it gets locked on
so
it's not like okay uh i'm using only 4
gb ram out of this
9 gb of ram then the next 5 gb of ram
will be totally wasted so you cannot
reuse it for any purpose
so this is a problem with the virtual
machine that
if you allocate some memory to the uh
specific virtual machine
if you are not using that much uh
resources or that much memory
the remaining memory will be simply
wasted because this is hardcorely
allocated to virtual machine and you
cannot utilize this
unused memory as such over there so this
is the limitation from the memory
perspective
but in case of docker definitely if you
know out of the
9gb of ram if we are using uh only 3gb
of ram
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually use it to
for the new containers so it's not
dedicatedly allocated to the virtual
machines
if you are using out of 9gb if you are
using 1gb 2gb 3gb or 4gb
whatever the remaining memory is
available that you can simply use it for
the other containers also
this ensures that you always go for an
optimal utilization of your resources
and unnecessarily there is no wastage of
the
different different resources or the
different components over here in this
one so
that's the reason why the docker
containers are quite uh
efficient in terms of memory when we
compare it with the virtual machine
next one is the performance now um in a
virtual machine
we know that you know on the
infrastructure on the physical
infrastructure
on top of that you put up a kind of
operating system a base operating system
is there
and then on top of that you have the
hypervisor and this hypervisor then is
used to create the virtual machines
which is having a kind of guest
operating system inside it
now the issue over here is that you have
two operating systems over here so the
guest operating system
is also going to take some particular
resources
and uh for example memory or a space
processor so in every terms in every
resource terms it
is going to go ahead and say that
okay i'm going to use the particular
some of the resources
now problem is that if you're hosting a
very small application
you will end up in having a more
consumption because of this guest
operating system will take more
more of the resources and then you are
just using some
small very small resources for your
application in an
uh real world so docker container on the
other hand does not have a concept of
the
guest operating system and that's where
what happens that the docker engine is
more than sufficient to handle the
docker containers and inside the docker
containers
there is the application which is being
hosted over there
now with this one definitely the
performance is quite better
as compared to any virtual machine
because of the terms that
there is no unnecessarily wasted of the
resources
because in the previous case virtual
machines a full-fledged guest operating
system is
up and running you need some resources
to be allocated to that
but in case of containers you don't need
to have that particular functionality
implemented
then portability so um you know having a
portability
or moving an application which works on
a system a
does not means that it will work on the
system b also this is a similar problem
which we face that you know the
usually the application works perfectly
fine in a lower environment
and when it goes to the production
environment it sometimes fails and uh
it does not comes up properly so this
isn't portability issue which we have
when we talk about the virtual machines
but when in case of containers when we
got a container up and running in a
lower environment
and once the container is prepared you
don't have to do the changes on
modification to that depending on the
environment
the same container can be deployed in
production environment and
it's very easy so whatever container
prepared in the lower environment in a
dev environment
the same will work in production
environment without any issues because
it contains all the dependencies and
executables everything inside it so
you don't have to do any kind of
modifications
or changes to these containers as such
over here
and the last one is a boot up time so
the boot up time of
the virtual machines is in minutes and
whereas the boot up time of
the docker containers is in seconds or
probably in
milliseconds so these are the reason why
we consider the virtual machine
as an uh resources based uh
environment but on the other hand docker
is something which is quite light
and fast as compared to virtual machines
so
let's see that what exactly is in docker
all about here so in this one you can
see
uh we have the physical infrastructure
on which we have
the host operating system now we don't
have the hypervisor and the guest
operating system
instead of that we have the docker
engine which is taking care of
managing the docker containers and
inside these docker containers you have
the applications
and all the required binaries and the
libraries here
so there is no concept of the gift
operating system these
docker engine is the person or is the
process which
is taking care of all the requests which
is going on
and if this docker engine is up and
running then
all the containers will also be
accessible and will be available
now docker is nothing but a os level
virtualization
software platform that enables
developers and id administrators to
create
deploy and run applications in a docker
container with all its dependencies
so docker is a very important tool
nowadays if you want to look forward
to the host your application because of
its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the
changes uh depending on the platform or
depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing
will go till the production environment
now let's talk about what exactly is in
docker container here now docker
container is a lightweight
software package that uh includes all
the dependencies
whether it's a base operating system uh
some frameworks some
libraries it's it's something which is a
part of this one so that if you will be
uh if you want to host your application
you will be able to do that so it's a
complete package so both the source code
and the dependencies is what you put up
inside the docker containers
now within these docker containers you
can have
multiple applications there multiple
programming languages
multiple frameworks can be hosted there
in fact the databases also can be hosted
within these docker containers you can
host them
as such over there now one of the
different advantages of docker let's
talk about that
now the first one is the rapid
deployment so a rapid deployment is the
very first
advantages which we are getting over
here second quick
and easy configuration better efficiency
portability scalability and security
over here
now there are different ways in which we
can understand the
uh benefits or we can uh have the
understanding about the
docker here so uh these are some couple
of
uh benefits now let's take up uh take
them one by one the for the first one
is the deployment part so uh it's it
supports the rapid deployment
now just like a web application for
instance i want to deploy to website so
there are some couple of steps which
needs to be done across different
different environments like for example
if i have five
environments i have to do the deployment
the same steps in all the five
environments at the
different period of time now when we
talk about docker containers we don't
have to run those steps multiple times
because
once those steps are executed in one
docker container
the same docker container goes till the
production environment so you don't have
to
actually do a rebuild of the docker
containers and you can simply say that
okay
i have got the docker container here so
you can just run
one or two couple of commands and that
will help you to host your docker
containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work
into the production environment or into
the higher environments and then we goes
for the
uh quick and easy configurations so the
configurations of docker containers is
quite easy
you can have your own custom docker
images built out
the docker files so these processes can
be integrated
within the jenkins also so cicd is quite
possible with the help of docker if you
want to really do that
and then we have better efficiency yes
they have a better efficiency and the
resources management as compared to the
virtual machines portability
uh we have already thought about that
that it's easy to move from one
environment from one system to another
in fact it's easy from the developer
also so from one machine
from one developer to another developer
it's very easy to move these uh
different
docker containers then we have
scalability
scalability is also possible with this
docker containers
just like multiple virtual machines you
can also create multiple containers and
you can share the traffic out of that so
but that scalability and all is possible
with the orchestration tools
uh then security is there so you can
have your best practices of the security
implemented because
um it's just a kind of a virtualization
just like a virtual machine
so you have all the uh different uh
possibilities which is available
which you can explore when you talk when
you want to make these stock containers
secure
right so these were some of the benefits
which was there for
the docker here now let's talk about the
installation of docker here
now installation of docker is pretty
common and uh whatever platform you want
uh it's available over there so it's
available for ubuntu
windows it's available for mac operating
system
so for ubuntu you have to run the
commands
on the open to part operating system to
download it
and for windows it's actually having a
a particular exe file so you can go for
the installation of exe file
and then we have the mac operating
system so for mac operating system
you have the dmg files and when you do
the dmg file so
it will uh help you to install the
component over there
so mac you can also use the home view
wants to do the installation of that
particular component
now next one is the architecture of
docker now
the architecture of docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of docker here
the very first one is the as the client
facing is
the docker client now docker client or
you can say that docker cli
is available there now this is the
component it's a command line interface
which
takes up the request from the end user
like for example i'm running the command
so
it will take all the requests from me as
an end user
and it will send those particular things
or the requirements to the docker daemon
to the server
using the rest api interface so this
docker daemon is something which keeps
on running on the server
and it's a background process it gets
deployed as in service there
in case this docker demon is not
available or it's not up and running
you will not get the proper response
from the docker
command line here so in order to get all
your activity or your
procedures implemented you need to have
the docker
server or docker daemon up and running
in fact this docker cli can be
configured to connect to any other
servers or any other
different server docker daemon also so
it's a connectivity which is happening
over the rest api
interface where all the requests are
processed are sent to the docker demon
and whatever response is coming back
that is given back to the end user
so what are the different components of
docker here let's talk about that
so docker client consists of the cli
company uh like we have already
discussed so
that is something which is uh going to
take up all the
requests from the end user then um it's
using the rest api interface
which is there to have the connectivity
with the docker daemon
so docker daemon is uh something which
is always up and running so if you run
couple of commands like docker pull push
and also
that activity you are actually sending
the request to the docker demon and
docker daemon is actually doing all the
work so
it's not a docker client which is doing
it just taking its kind of interface
which will take the things up
and send it back or send it forward to
the docker day
right so it's a background process which
keeps on running on the server
on the operating system and uh it's the
same process across all the
infrastructure all the different
platforms whether you use mac operating
system use windows or you use
linux everywhere this is the basic
functionality
and it keeps on listening to the rest
api interface
so uh whatever the request new request
comes in it immediately process it
and whatever the response whether you
are stopping a container whether you are
running a container
according to that the action will be
taken and the response will be sent back
to the rest api
to the docker client so a docker is a
process or it's a command line which is
used to start the docker daemon
when you run the command like service
docker status on the server
you will be able to see the command
which is getting executed in the back
end
so there you can see that uh docker is
the process
or is the command line which is used to
initialize the docker daemon and
of course there is a kind of
configurations which you have to pass it
on as a
parameters so even if you run psiphony
of command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is
a particular docker registry so we have
a ready-made uh cloud
service which is available known as the
docker hub so
you can actually store the docker images
on these docker registry
so there are a lot of ready-made uh
docker images which is available there
but
of course you can have your own uh
docker image also over there
or you want you can have your own custom
registry docker registries also for
example in jfrog
you can have your private hosted
registries also so
all these uh different repositories you
can use
with your docker containers so docker
containers is having the flexibility
that
whichever registries or repositories you
want to connect or you want to
establish the connectivity you can
always do that now let's talk about the
docker image
over here in detail
now a docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions
it's having a couple of instructions in
which you will be using these
instructions to create a final dock
container
so docker image is uh nothing but uh
for example i want to have a tomcat
apache docker image
so what are the instructions i have to
do so the very first thing is that i
have to pick up a base operating system
then on top of that i will be installing
the jdk or some prerequisite packages
and then on top of that we will be
configuring on to the tonkit apache
there
so these are the steps these are the
different instructions step by step
procedure
which we are implementing so that at the
end
of the uh activity we will be able to
have a
docker container ready which we can
deploy to host
tomcat apache so it's a template which
is having all the
uh particular instructions in order to
build a docker image you require a file
called dockerfile
which is uh of course having all these
different uh
instructions embedded in that so when
you run the dockerfile it acts like a
build tool so whatever the instructions
you are
putting up over there all those
instructions are getting
processed and you are able to get an end
result
then these docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers
so multiple layers are available there
so step by step so you will be first of
all having a
base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk
so another layer will be there and then
you did the configuration
of the term kit apache and then another
layer will be there so it's a
multi-layered
in uh component which is available and
these layers are in
incremental order so definitely the
oldest one will be known as the base
layer and then on top of that all the
latest changes will be done in the
latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that
uh there are four instructions and these
four instructions are
also known as the four layer docker
image so whatever the final docker image
you will get
in there you will be able to see four
layers of uh the
docker image here now the very first is
ubuntu so ubuntu 18.04 we are pulling up
and then we are pulling
like uh the file over here and uh then
we are running the make utility
and uh once that is done then we are
running that file dot
uh python file over here in this one so
these are four instructions
which is available right so uh which
will definitely help us to do that how
exactly we can
make or we can perform the different
activities
right from the base so in this case the
base layer will be like
uh the one two one so one two one will
be the base image
and the moment the final cmd attribute
or cmd
uh attributions are processed and
executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full fledged docker image over
there
so this will be a full uh complete
docker image or docker container
which you will get once the whole build
process is completed
now in this case you have you can see
that the
previous docker file which we processed
so the base layer is ubuntu 18.04
we are not building that actually it's
automatically so
it's by default getting downloaded as in
full base layer
after that only we have like layer 1
layer 2 layer 3 added up because
those modifications we are doing it
after the because from does not means
that you are doing any kind of layer
modifications
it's just like you are importing some
base operating system or base image
so the modification or adding up the
layers is only
done after the base layer there so
whenever a user creates a container a
new
uh layer is something which is stopped
on top of the image these layers are
known as the
containers layers so one to one the very
first instruction does not comprises it
it is it's not a kind of a container
layer we can call it as
an base image layer there so every
container
has a separate read write container
layer and any modification in a
container is reflected
upon the container layers only so layer
one may be having some different of uh
instructions later may be having
different instructions so like that is a
diff
step by step processor in case
you know whenever a container is deleted
the top layer also gets deleted
over there in that one so if i delete
some
particular containers and that is
something which is gone
so it was suppose having like three
layers so the top layer will be simply
deleted
because the container is also deleted
for that particular part
now docker uses a copy and write
strategy with both docker images and
docker containers so whenever we uh
perform any activity or whenever copy on
uh right strategies and strategy to
share and copy files for better
efficiency so
it's something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers
it also makes docker efficient by
reducing the uses of disk space because
whenever uh required okay whenever is
needed
only at that moment of time it's
actually performing the copy
and uh it definitely reduces the overall
disk utilization and
this is very important also because when
you have so many docker containers up
and running
so you have to worry or you have to make
the utilization of a disk or your
disk users or resources also minimum so
that is also you need to make sure that
it does not exceed a particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about some of the facts
here so the base layers
are something which is purely read-only
format so you cannot do the
modifications
union file system saves the memory uh
you know by avoiding the duplications of
the files
uh the layers can be combined in a union
file system
to create a single image so all these
layers are combined and
got a final product or called a you know
you can call it as docker image or
docker containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a write table
which is known as copy on right so copy
and write
strategy is being used so to do the
changes or to
do the perform the modifications of this
union file system while
creating the different different layers
so
now let's talk about the docker registry
very important component because
even if you prepare the docker image
locally and
you don't have the collaborative tool or
you don't have the
uh tool where you can share these images
definitely it's not
easy for you to port these docker images
from one system to another
so docker registry is very important for
the portability
feature of docker so docker registry is
a service
to host and distribute docker images
among users so
uh it can be built up by one user and
multiple users can use it for example
i'm using a jenkins one so jenkins
uh image is prepared only once but it's
being used by different people
as such docker registry uh again it's a
repository is a collection of docker
images so in a repository you will be
having like different different uh
docker images as such so in registry
a user can distinguish between the
docker images
with their tag names so uh for example
jenkins
is an a kind of a single image there
might be different
type of images there let's say that okay
let's talk about uh
jenkins uh jdk8 so there will be image
called jenkins the name of the image
will be same but the tags will be
different
so one tag could be like jdk8 one tag
would be like
jk9 and one tag would be dedicated so
the difference between all these three
docker images is that
that jdk81 is prepared on jdk8
it's running on jdk8 and if you want to
use jk9 in that case you have to pull
down
the the docker image of jenkins with the
jdk 9
installed so depending on the frameworks
or depending on the runtimes
so with these tags different tags are
processed so you can have the
distinguish between the
docker images and whichever docker image
you feel you want to use
you can implement according to your
requirement and uh
docker by default is having its own uh
cloud-based registry called as docker
hub
which gets automatically connected when
the moment you do the docker
installation
but in case you are working into your
private infrastructure
so in that case uh you may use the
repositories uh docker repositories
on the uh specific jfrog artifactory or
the private repositories also can be
hosted
but docker hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both
so you can create either the public and
private repositories
you can use uh push and pull activities
to interact with these docker images
you want to download a docker image so
you can run pull if you want to push
your docker image to the
docker registry in that case you can run
the push activity
so in both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the
uh docker hub so when you run some build
process or when you run the containers
there may be some docker containers
which is getting pulled down from the
specific registry from the docker hub
and uh if that specific image and tag is
available
definitely pull command will be
successful but in case of push command
you are pushing your custom docker
images uh you cannot push the
ready-made docker images which is
available you can publish your own
docker image only to the
docker hub and then you can further on
do the poll and push activity
accordingly to those repositories
so whatever the ready-made and
third-party images which is available
you can only do the pull activities to
them you cannot do the push activities
push command scenario will only come
when you are looking
when you are interacting with your
custom docker image next one is the
docker container
now docker container is an executable
package of an application
and its dependencies together so when we
prepare a docker container we actually
combine both the dependencies
and the application source code inside
it so the docker container don't have to
look for the dependencies on the host
machine on the server
so this is one of the benefit where we
see that
the portability is very easy because
whatever i'm building up
on one system everything is inside the
docker container so i don't really
need to do any further activity on other
machines
so whatever works on one system can be
easily worked on in the system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed
on you know on their particular uh
servers because it does not take
that much utilization like a virtual
machine so if you are looking forward
for having your application hosted into
your local system
you can easily do it within the docker
container so the utilization is very
less
as compared to the virtual machine so
you don't have to worry about your
operating host operating system and the
qualifications
so docker containers can run in totally
isolation just like a virtual machine
so there is no interaction or there is
no interference
so they share the os called uh kernel
but the thing is they don't have the
interface
as such over there so it works totally
in isolation
uh two different containers will not
have any interaction unless and until we
do
we set up that the containers to have
the interactions
now there is uh data volumes where which
can be shared
and uh be used among the multiple
containers
so um you have the uh capability over
here that
you know if the there is some on
used uh space that can be easily shared
across the multiple containers here
so uh it is uh built using the docker
images so
uh using the docker images the docker
containers are built up
and docker run is a specific command
which is used to build a docker
container
so if you got a docker image let's say
that i have prepared a docker image a
custom docker image using the docker
file
now if i need to create a docker
container out of a docker image
i have to run a docker run command so
docker run command is nothing
but it initializes or creates an
instance of a docker image
now next component is the docker compose
now
typically when we work with the the
docker containers
so we have to run like if i want to run
like five six containers
i have to initialize like five six times
or i have to run docker and commands
five six times there so um and if you
want to create a relationship between
the containers
then definitely that is something which
you need to manage using the docker
commands
but sometimes it's not an easy task for
you to run those commands manually or
remember those commands
so docker compose is a utility over here
using which you can actually run
multiple containers with a single
service you just got off
a kind of a single file you just run it
and all the containers definitions and
relationships
everything is inside this docker file
here so you want to run two containers
that's totally fine instead of running
two commands now you just have to run
one file and that will do
take care of that now you may be having
more than two containers five six seven
whatever number of containers you have
that can be easily deployed without any
manual activity or without any
maintainers onto the server
so these containers totally run in
isolation but yes
you can establish the interaction that
how they want to
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these
docker compose file so docker compose
file is something which is written in
the vml format
and in this you define that okay i need
two containers
and this in this image should be there
these are the parameters which you need
to run
and if you want to have the interaction
or the linkage between the images
that also you can establish within this
yml files or this in within this
docker compose file here right so let's
say for example i want to
have an application which requires
apache web server and mysql database
now i can create a docker compose file
which can run both containers
and uh without you know you don't
require to restart or start them
separately or initialize them separately
so i will be having a final docker
compose file which is having like uh
you know containers like apache
containers and mysql containers
both inside a single docker compose file
here so that's
the benefit you're going to get because
now you don't have to run them
separately
separate apache and separate via mysql
so
you can get it done with the help of a
single docker compose file here
now what exactly is the docker swamp now
docker swamp
is a inbuilt or it's a default
orchestration tool which is being
provided by the docker itself
it's a service for containers which
allows the i t administrators
and the developers to create and manage
a cluster of
smart nodes so in a typical world when
you do the installation of docker
there is a limitation that you some of
the features like high ability
multiple uh instances or scalability
all these things are not possible as it
is with the core docker
now on top of that you require the
organization tools like docker swamp
where you have a swam of node machines
uh five six known machines are there on
which you can have your
highly available application
infrastructure implemented
now this one means that if i want to run
my uh
applications five containers six
containers and seven containers
for that purpose we are using the docker
spam so each node of docker swam
is having a docker daemon which is uh
used to for performing the interaction
so there will be a master node which is
available so
uh it will be interacting with all the
known machine on the all the client
machines
and this interaction will be in such a
way that it will let them know
okay i want to deploy the container or
onto the note 3 so it will perform that
activity and the container will be up
and running on the note 3 there
so a swamp consists of two type of nodes
one is the manager node and button is a
worker node
so manager is the master node which you
can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so
uh the manager node is not something
which is expected to host
anything apart from the main component
but yes
you can always configure if you feel
that you want to only
deploy the container on the worker node
so that also you can
do during the deployment of the
containers so manager will
will keep on connecting to the different
worker nodes there and whenever new
request comes in so it will basically
try to connect and see that okay i just
want to go ahead and
deploy a container so it will do the
deployment of the container on the
worker node
so the main work will be done by the
worker nodes and manager is just doing
the management of all these resources
the worker nodes will be definitely
receiving the request from the manager
and
it will be proceeding and performing
those activities
and uh if for some reason worker node is
not active or online
so the master node will not be able to
deploy the containers on that server so
right now let's talk about a demo in
which we have to
create a docker image using a docker
file on the open220 so
uh you want to use a base operating
system as an ubuntu 20 there and using
that we will we are going to create a
custom docker
image so let's connect to our virtual
machine and see that how we can
do that okay so as part of this
demo here we are going to prepare a
docker image and uh
in that we are going to use a base image
of ubuntu
so uh let's take an operating system of
ubuntu 220
20 is the latest version of the ubuntu
operating system so i have got a server
so let's see
so first of all we have to install the
docker.io package which will install the
docker package and then we can
enable the service we can make sure that
the docker service is up and running
because
if the service itself is down then we
will not be able to perform any activity
and then our sample if you run docker
run hello hyphen volt so that is going
to pull
a docker image from the docker hub and a
particular activity will be done to you
so once that is done so we can say that
okay the container is up and running and
everything is got uh you know over there
up and running and then you can also
try some of the ubuntu uh docker image
also if you feel that you want to try
you can do that
but the main uh demo which we need to do
over here is that we need to prepare a
custom docker image
and in this one we will be having like
we will be using an
ubuntu base operating system on top of
that we will be installing php engine x
all these different components so we are
going to have a php based website hosted
onto the apache web server as an nginx
and then we will be able to access that
application
so the very first thing which we need to
do is that we need to create a folder uh
let's say that i just create a
particular folder called
nginx hyphen image and then i create a
docker file over there
so docker file uh content we are going
to take from this one so let's go to the
server and see that how we can go ahead
with the activity
now uh what we can do is that what uh
we have got a server over here now in
this server what i'm going to do is that
i'm going to proceed with the
installation of docker first
now when i do the docker installation
first so what will happen
that i will be able to have my docker
installation completed and then further
on
i can take the further steps of having
the accessibility of
uh going through the understanding that
what is this uh particular platform or
how to prepare different different kind
of containers
so i have got a particular container
over here so what i can really do is
that
i can simply say that okay i have got a
server so this is a one-two server so i
am going to run the command called app
update first
now this will do the update locally so
all the
links and everything will be updated now
the whole idea about doing the updates
is that
so that i will be able to ha establish
the fact that
i'm trying to connect i'm trying to
connect with the ubuntu url so that
at any moment of time i should be able
to fetch on the
latest packages now once that is done so
i'm going to run the command called apt
install docker.io
now the moment i do this what will
happen that it will try to download some
packages it will ask for the
confirmation you can give your
confirmation
and i can say yes the moment you give
the confirmations the
download of the packages will proceed
over here step by step it will download
the packages and the installation will
go on
now once the installation is done so
what you can do is that you can see
that docker is uh deployed into your
system or not
you can run docker version command or
you can also use this service command to
check
to make sure to ensure that the docker
service is always
up and running if the service is not up
and running you have to make sure you
have to enable it you have to start that
service
so these are some couple of steps which
you need to do in order to make sure
that your
connectivity or your environment is
ready for with the docker installation
and once the docker installation is done
then only you will be able to proceed
further
with the further activities like
preparing the containers preparing the
images and all that stuff
but if you don't have the docker
installed prior to that then definitely
it's going to be a problem so
just make sure that before even doing
any kind of activity before even doing
any kind of uh
steps we ensure that the docker is fully
up and running
so it's going to take some time to
download the packages and we will wait
for that and once the installation is
done
we will continue further on that part
okay
now once the installation is done so you
can run the command call service
docker status and when you do that
it will let you know that whether the
docker service is available there or not
so uh you can start the service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response
and uh now you can see that it's showing
up that
a process is running so earlier it was
not uh
up and running it was inactive but now
it's active
and you can see here that dark ride is
the process which is running over here
as an uh process to initialize the
docker damage so docker demon is up and
running now
and we are good to go here so now uh if
we go
and say like docker run
hello hyphen vault so we are
doing a validation to our docker
instance that whether our docker
instance is working fine as expected or
not because
uh if there is any kind of problem with
the docker daemon and docker demon is
not up and running properly
we would be able to get an error message
over there but right now there is no
error message which
represents that yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh
docker images when you run so you will
be able to see
that the docker image is pulled down to
your system and definitely you have
executed that and
it got you the response now the next
thing which we need to do is that
we need to run a particular ubuntu one
so for example
if i go for docker run
hyphen id open to bash
so what exactly we are doing in this one
is that we are pulling down a ubuntu
docker image
and we are running the bash executable
on top of that the whole purpose of
doing that activity is that so that if
i want to do some uh process or i want
to perform some activity
i should be able to connect to that
docker image so the moment i do this
first of all if this docker image is
available locally that's great
it will immediately create the container
if the docker image is not
available locally the very first thing
which it will perform over here is to
pull down the docker image the correct
one
and as you can see here that it uh
definitely pulls down the darker image
and once it is done so it got a terminal
for you now you can see
it shows that root at the id uh root and
the rate of one id is there
this id is nothing but it's a container
id which we are getting here
so definitely you are inside the docker
container and when you run the docker
when you run the exit command you will
see that you have come
out of the docker container over here
and the moment you run docker ps hyphen
a command
you can actually see also that how many
container you deployed so far
so you ran hello world you ran the one
to one both of them are stopped there
you can see the exit zero in the uh
status over here
because both of them are something which
you ran in the interactive mode so they
are done
so if you want to keep your container up
and running you need to have
a container which runs in the dash mode
and always up and running
but for that you have to go ahead to the
level where we need to create a custom
docker image
and do the setup accordingly so let's
see that how we can do that now i'm
going to create a particular folder
called
nginx hyphen image you can pretty much
give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
i'm going to put up a file called
dockerfile
so let's see that what content we need
to put as such when you talk about the
docker file because
whatever content you put over here that
is what according which the docker image
will be prepared
now here we have to talk about so first
we have to see a base image
so we are saying that okay 0.220.04 is
what i want to use
then we are giving some labels now these
labels are used to give some information
like
uh what is the version who is the
maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so
uh these labels are actually defined and
utilized so that i will be able to give
an information that okay
so and so developer is something which
we can contact so if there is any kind
of problem with the
uh docker file or will this build script
we
have to reach out to that specific
person so this is what we typically do
with the labels here
now um we also have to set up a
parameter like
deviant underscore fronted as in
non-interactive because
whenever we talk about any build process
in docker file it
it cannot be there in the interactive
session it should be there in the
non-interactive and definitely a typical
uh scenarios like you can run app update
command and then
we are installing the php and super
supervisor
all these things we are doing we are
doing the installation uh we
are using the run attribute run a
particular step
and in there whatever the commands are
executed these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process
and then we are using some environment
variables okay so
nginx via virtual host php underscore
conf engine extenders for conf and
supervisor and disco conf these are the
different environment variables
which we configuring over here now next
thing which we have is that uh
we have to transfer some files like
probably nginx and
the virtual host file we may have to
transfer from our
linux server to the destination to the
docker container so for that we are
going to run some copy commands
copy statements so that we can do that
stuff and uh
then definitely we are transferring the
supervisor
configuration file also to the server so
that we can have that
configurations uh setup over there and
uh
these are config uh supervisor
underscore config and all these
different
variables we have already established
where we are seeing that what exactly
configuration we are looking forward
over here
and then we are uh you know creating
some folder structure we
had www html folder structure we are
creating so that we will be able to push
some content over there
and then we have the volume
configurations so whatever the volume
configurations are there we are putting
up so that
uh you know we will be able to have all
the uh
specific direct directories mounted on
the host machine on the host server so
that we can even
talk about locally also and then the
star.search is something which we need
to run because
that's uh that will go into the command
statement which
needs to be executed because when you
want to run your process when you want
to run
your nginx process or your docker
container some process should be up and
running that's where
if any interactive process will run then
only the
docker container will be hold up so
that's what you can
do or you can configure over there so
i'm going to copy this whole content
now this whole content represents the
complete docker file
so uh we have already gone through this
content one by one but uh
if we combine all these content together
till the exposed part
that's where we come up into these ones
so expose we are doing 80 and 443 over
here
right after this one we have to create
the host file virtual host file
supervisor d file and the start.search
file
so let's go back to the server here now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that
so this is what i will my master file
will look like you can see i'm running
some run commands
uh these are the environment variables
i'm using then further on this variables
i'm using
just to define the paths okay so you can
see that this default file we are
copying from the
uh host machine from the server to the
docker container and then second file is
super
wiser d not con file and then we have
star dot sh file so these are the
different files which we want to
configure here so once this file is
prepared we have to uh
type in or we have to create a default
file over here in this current directory
so in this current directory we have to
put up a file called default
now in this one we will be having the
default virtual host configuration
config
so we need to put our server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files
from the www.html directory there so i'm
just going to copy this content
and uh put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so i'll save it
and uh then we have a supervisord dot
com file so
so i'll just copy the content of this
one
i'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
supervisord.confile
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into our
docker file so
we can double check that so once this is
done
save it and we can check
the docker file we can grab
so you can see okay this one so super
wiser d so the name is correct that
scroll
so we got default we got supervisor d
now we have to create the
star dot sh file because in this one we
will be configuring
that how we want to start our process of
this nginx or this web server
so in this one again we have to run the
uh supervised
process over here and a configuration
file so we are going to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised config
also available so that's also there
and the moment is done so you are going
to give the execute permission to this
one because
you can see that into our docker file
that
we are having the attribute where we
want to run this into the dots
slash there so if you want to refer in
that mode you have to change the
permissions in case so that
change mode you have to give the execute
permission to the start dot sh here
now once this is done
so what you got is that you got a
particular
components like you got uh some couple
of commands
you have uh you know got docker file
super
isd.conf default all these files are
there now the only thing which we need
to do next is that we need to build to
the build process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process what happens that docker build
is the command which we need to use and
uh nginx iphone image is the name which
you want to refer
now you can totally use this uh custom
name
whatever name you feel that you want to
use you can always use that
there's no restriction on that part and
once that is on
so you will be able to list down those
images that you got a new custom docker
image here so you can see
that you got the ubuntu as a base image
which is built down and the nginx iphone
image is also prepared over there
and once that is done so you are going
to create a web root folder
and uh you can run the docker run
command to see that if
you really got connected with that
particular one so let's go back and uh
see that how we can create uh the
docker custom docker image here so the
moment i do this
so it will pick up the docker file over
here and start
performing the activities uh the package
installations all those configurations
ones will be performed over here in a
non-interactive mode
there is no confirmation which will be
asked from the user because you cannot
put that confirmations so the command
should be in such a way that it should
not take any kind of confirmations at
all from the
end user so because tomorrow you may be
putting up these things in the jenkins
so
that will not be a feasible thing for
you to put up the commands and
put up the confirmations during the
execution so
so it's trying to run do the package
installation for the php so fbm packages
are getting installed
and here we go so we caught
the successful message now you can see
it says
successfully tag this one this means
that there is
no issues at all with the docker image
and when you run the darker
images or darker images ls you can run
these two couple of commands
so when you do that you got a 203 37
mb of the size of this image that
represents that this docker image is
fully ready to run
to a secured so now what we are going to
do is that we are going to
map a volume over here with the www.html
directory during the execution of this
container because
i really want to deploy some pages and
web pages there if you have the web
pages now
as part of the build process as part of
the docker file you can do a git clone
also
of some repository but i don't want to
do that uh
during the preparation of docker image i
just now got an environment
where the nginx is set up properly and
it's up and running there
now it should be upon me that how i want
to put up my content and all
so that's the reason why i'm putting up
a kind of a folder structure over here
and sharing it with the docker container
so that the moment i put the
html files or the php files into that
local folder i should be able to
get some web page up and running there
so that's what i'm going to do
over here in this one so i'm going to
create a folder structure
saying slash web root here okay so
there is a folder structure which is
created now in this web root i will be
putting up some files and then same
files
will be redirected inside the docker
container with the help of docker volume
so
let's go back to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like i
said that
uh you are going to connect on that part
okay
so uh you can use this port as an at
also but here
it it is used so whatever port you feel
you want to use you can do that
and we are giving the container name as
test and iphone container that also you
can change
and genix hyphen image is the one which
we are using so if you use some
different uh
particular image you can also use that
and uh you can see that
the web route is something which we are
connecting with the www.html directory
so the moment you put some file in the
web root the same file will be reflected
into the
www.html directory there so i'm going to
run this command
and once this is done so you can see
that for the testing purpose
we are putting up some content in the
html one so i'll come to that point also
and we'll validate
as of now we should be having our
container up and running over here in
this one
now i'm going to copy that command okay
and hit on so if uh the at port is used
so you have to make sure that port uh
gets uh you know
gets stopped automatically or it should
not be up and running so
just double check whatever port you're
using that should be free now when you
run the docker ps command
so uh you will be able to see a docker
container up and running
but if you see like docker ps iphone a
that gives
also these stopped and running both the
containers are there
but the main thing which we want to run
is that we want to run the docker ps
command and you can see
that this is a container which is
running so 8080 is the container which
is running and test hyphen container is
the name
now you got a container up and running
so you can actually do a call
on localhost colon 8080 so um
this is a way to get the content uh you
can get the public ip also and uh in the
browser you can put up and you can have
the content there
but right now uh we are getting the
response at least uh it's
showing his 403 error forwarding error
but that's fine we will be putting up
some web pages there in the rw html
directory
or we can say in local web root
directory so that we will be able to
have some content
so what we can do is that we can have
some echo commands
executed so that we can have some added
some content added up into the
uh particular uh files there so let's
see that what different contents we can
do
so uh you can use the vi mode also to do
a
uh you know couple of files so i'm just
using this echo command
so um the moment i go for this
execution so what happens that a file
will be created
into that uh slash web route there so
i'm expecting that i have put up a
index.html page
so if you feel that you want to put some
different page you can always do
and uh the moment you do the curl now
you will be able to see the same
response so whatever the things you put
up in the index.html file
the same content is going to pop up when
you run the curl command
now um you want to use some php files
you want to put up some php content all
that stuff you can do it
now what i'm going to do is that rather
than just a html static content i'm
going to put some php content
that uh is going to help me to get a
file so
my web root will have now two files so
uh
if if you feel uh that index.html file
should have some meaningful content you
can always do that
you can pull some of the websites also
you can put that into the
you can do a git clone in the web root
and the whole application will be
started
and uh now if you feel that i got a
info.php file so
i can use the nut name into the url i
have to modify the url because
uh index.html file is the what as in
default name page you do
if you want to put up some different
name you can change the server
configuration of nginx and according to
that it will work
so um when i do this so you will start
getting
the output so this is the php content
output which is there it's a complete
information
now it may look like a very bulky
content to you but when you put up this
one
into the browser into the web browser
that will be a meaningful information
probably
in terms of some tables or something
like that right
so um let me scroll to the top here so
you can see that
it's showing an error sorry it's showing
in the output and this output represents
that
you got a particular php content here so
this is
how we will be able to have a container
and uh
you know this container is up and
running you can modify to at any level
you feel that you want to prepare a
darker image with the code embedded also
you can have the git clone or you can
have this configuration into some git
repository
have the source code also there and then
prepare a complete bundle altogether
so this is what we have in this demo how
we can deploy a container
and a container up and running in case
of the docker here
so that was the demo right uh which we
took to create a docker custom docker
image on
using the dockerfile on ubuntu right so
that's it for this uh
lesson thanks everyone
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here